like thousands of others josten
nicknamed angel went out to protest on
the streets of mandalay on wednesday
less than 24 hours later people gathered
for her funeral
she had been shot in the head according
to the u.n angel was
one of 38 protesters who died at the
hands of myanmar security forces
the most killed in a single day since
the coup on february 1st
aid agency save the children says four
of the dead were children
in yangon bodies were identified and
collected by family members
this neighborhood of the country's
largest city saw the heaviest death toll
on wednesday
there are reports that security forces
opened up with live ammunition on the
unarmed protesters
without warning but the protesters
continue to put pressure on the junta
on thursday again building barricades to
block the security forces as they
prepare
for another day of protests yangi li
is the former un special rapporteur from
myanmar she and two other experts have
started a council to track the situation
after the coup the behaviors the actions
of this
so-called military
are uh terrorist-like behaviors
they have snipers and and
on high-rise buildings or on tall
buildings
they are aiming at and shooting at
the civilian population this is a
question
and she said that the international
community needs to acknowledge the
military's actions as being comparable
to terrorism u.n you know
they should really be ashamed of what
they've
done or not done you know they haven't
been
adhering to the un charter to protect
uh and to restore or to
maintain or to secure peace and order
and the security council have have
really not done
its job she went on to say that china
and russia's veto power in the u.n
security council is obstructing action
that needs to be taken in myanmar
so far the council has voiced concern
but has not condemned what's happened
since the coup but there will be a
further test of that on friday as
another security council meeting has
been called to discuss the crackdown of
protesters
this week scott heidler al jazeera minzo
who's the executive director of the
myanmar institute for peace and security
he's joining us by skype
from yangon it's good to have you with
us on al jazeera
when you and i were talking a few weeks
ago about this situation you were
explaining the protesters determination
to keep on
keep pressure on the military junta
we're now a few weeks down the line
we've seen an increase in violence we've
seen
deaths and we've seen an increasing
number of people getting injured as well
how are people feeling about this now
people are very angry at the security
forces especially at the military
and police people witnessed a crackdown
and the use of force uh very
unproportionate
uh to the uh peaceful protesters
on the other hand the regime appeared to
be quite determined
to use fools to crack it down while we
saw the major troop movements
on february
26 to major cities to reinforce the
existing security forces
and the nationwide crackdown started
on february 28th and
we noticed although the number of
protests
and the number crops became smaller
people remained defiant
in major cities and the military also
continued the crackdowns
so it seems like the both sides are in a
difficult situations
and and really uh said for
the country that it seems like
we may see more bloodshed in comedies as
well
we saw pictures recently of one medical
team being attacked uh by security
forces because they've been helping
demonstrators the un rights chief
michelle bashley has just been reporting
at least 29 journalists
have apparently been arrested in recent
days how concerned are you
that support for the protest is going to
start to thin out
as people get more scared
yeah right now the arrests being taken
place targeting the
uh the leaders and organizer of the
protests
so usually uh what happened was the uh
the security forces rounded up
uh the protester in the daytime and they
kept them overnight and they
investigate them and usually they
release
some protesters who are not the
organizers
but they continue to rate places where
they
thought uh the organizers uh may be
hiding as well
so uh we also uh uh see that some of the
journalists were also
uh arrested and some of them were
released as well
uh so uh is it's difficult to
uh determine the extent uh because of
the
uh murky situations but one thing what
we can tell is the reaching
is quite determined to crack it down and
targeting the organizers
of the protest and also uh the uh
leaders of the nld
who are taking part in the parallel
government uh
challenging the regime we've heard a lot
about the international
um criticism of what's been going on uh
in
myanmar but at the moment a lot of it
seems to be
words it just seems to be rhetoric what
would the protesters
want to see from the international
community in terms of
actual action against the the military
junta in
myanmar
they are like a widespread uh call for
the united nations to et
uh on myanmar uh but at the same time
the protesters
are quite impatient
at the united nations in in capability
uh to act decisively
on myanmar crisis as well so there also
uh understanding among some of the
opposition that
uh this is the fight myanmar people
have to take on by their own rather than
relying on the international communities
minso is executive director of the
myanmar institute for peace and security
we appreciate you being with us on al
jazeera thank you
thank you